mich stört die dreiste doppelmoral von
deutschlands macht elite wahrscheinlich
denken sie jetzt worüber regt sich die
blonde frau hier wieder auf aber wenn
sie diese bilder sehen dann werden sie
mir recht geben da bin ich mir ganz
sicher wir alle bürger wir müssen ja im
flugzeug maske tragen und werden sogar
geweckt dass es mir schon mal passiert
wenn diese mal verrutscht kein scherz
aber spitzenpolitiker wie robert habeck
und auch hauptstadtjournalisten die man
hier sind im regierungsflieger dürfen
ohne maske fliegen der grund sei dass
alle einen pcr-test abgelegt hätten wenn
ich aber einen mache nun ja da muss ich
trotzdem die maske aufziehen ich will da
ist ja gar nicht schlecht reden hier ich
finde es großartig wenn endlich robert
habeck sagt ach ich trage die maske
nicht mehr im flugzeug fans am großartig
wenn das haupt versäumnissen tun aber
warum müssen wir bürger ist da noch tun
und jetzt jetzt kommt der super gau die
masken pflicht im flugzeug wurde heute
noch mal verschärft laut exklusiven bild
informationen will das bundeskabinett an
bord von flugzeugen bald nur noch die
fsg zwei masken erlauben da frage ich
mich wieder sein kann fast ganz europa
verzichtet auf die massen pflicht im
flugzeug und jetzt geht natürlich die
frage an den spd-bundestagsabgeordneten
der runde herald freuen sie sich denn
schon darauf bald im flugzeug nur noch
mit ft2 maske sitzen zu dürfen
also ich hab ja immer eine ft2 moskau
auf lena wollte ich nicht zwei masken
bei mir habe also ich tragen welche da
ist man immer richtig mit angezogen ich
würde mich freuen wenn die maske nicht
mehr brauchen würden solange unsere
experten meinen wir brauchen sie muss
ich das auch akzeptieren und denkt wenn
er nicht manchmal darüber nach und fragt
sich sophie warum sind wir denn hier in
deutschland die einzigen was soll denn
dieser sonderweg ich möchte hier gerne
mal einen tweet zeigen wir haben ja
jetzt den kanzler aus deiner partei oder
abseits ich möchte hier gerne mal zu
zeigen was armin laschet eigentlich
darüber denkt er wäre ja beinahe unser
kanzler geworden er hat dazu getwittert
denn auch ihm macht das sauer was da
eigentlich abgeht gerade und ganz
versteht er es auch nicht den schweiz
zeigen wir einmal hier und zwar sagt er
nämlich es gibt dem
infektionsschutzgesetz keine ausnahme
für regierungsflieger aber merkt
eigentlich niemand dass es fast
schlimmer wäre wenn es ausnahmen für
regierende gäbe fast ganz europa
verzichtet auf masse nicht weil zumeist
niedrigen inzidenz und warum dieser
deutsche alleingang also wenn armin
laschet ihr uns fragt warum dieser
deutsche alleingang was ist die
entgegnung weil unser
gesundheitsminister das für die beste
lösung hält ja wir werden wir haben
jetzt auch die sommerpause wir treffen
uns nächste woche zur fraktionsklausur
und da werden wir hoffentlich auch neben
allen energiefragen die wir hier
diskutieren werden über das
infektionsschutzgesetz diskutieren und
dann würde ich mich dann auch wieder
eine oder andere antwort an freunde
haben wir das ist auch fast pervers ich
meine wir haben jetzt das oktoberfest in
münchen
und da gibt es keine maske pflicht aber
wenn ich heute bin ich mit dem zug von
münchen nach berlin gefahren und musste
vier stunden diese maske tragen und als
ich sie runter genommen habe weil ich
ein stück schokolade essen wollte kamen
die zugbegleiterin und sagte bitte
setzen sie gleich wie die ihre maske auf
also noch wenig gekauft habe wir kennen
doch dieses doppel denken schon aus der
römischen zeit ich weiß wer von ihnen
latäng gehabt hat wie cdu-vize bogen aus
dem jupiter erlaubt es ist dem rindvieh
nicht erlaubt aus einem habe erlaubt ist
es ihnen hier nicht erlaubt ja diese
doppelmoral
ich erwarte von einem politiker
in der kategorie a b oder c der
volksvertreter ist dass er auch vorbild
für das volk ist und da kann er nicht
jetzt darum tanzen und ohne also sie
sind weiter für die massen pflicht im
flugzeug das hat damit gar nichts zu tun
aber dann ist jetzt vielleicht soll ein
vorbild weil er sich nicht daran hält
naja angesetztes brüssel halten dann
muss es sich mit seinem superschlauen
gesundheitsminister der ja auch oft
morgen nicht mehr weiß was er gestern
gesagt hat auseinandersetzen ja also
nein für mich ist der herr lauterbach
mit verlaub erhalten keine kapazität vor
allem weil er so redet mal sorry das ok
hat sich über talkshows über 40
talkshows im jahr 2021 auf einen
ministerposten hinein gelabert aber
ich glaube dass mittlerweile die
fraktion oder auch der kanzler nicht
mehr so ganz glücklich mit ihm ist
werbung für den kauf online kauf von
bestimmten
impfstoffen und weise also andere ich
mach das jetzt nicht mehr aber ich
glaube also die masken pflicht gilt
tatsächlich im öffentlichen nahverkehr
also in fernzügen und den linienflügen
das ist jetzt natürlich ein formales
argument und ich stimme ihm völlig zu
heraus dass quasi politikern vorbild
sein sollten ich habe zu einem für die
reaktivierung einer bahnstrecke der
letzten woche auch eine fahrt gemacht
eine sonderfahrt eine angemeldete
sonderfahrt und haben wir an bord
diskutiert haben wir auch keine maske
getragen es gab auch kritik dann macht
gar nicht daran gedacht aber es war halt
ne für ein faktisch gesehen kein
öffentlicher nahverkehr ich gebe das
hier auch zu ja ganz schuldbewusst
hätten wir machen können darum schuld
bewusst da er schuld bewusst war wie
sich wohl herrn regeln lade politik hat
sich an regeln halten
verfilmen lassen dann darf ich nicht das
hat jetzt mit maske nichts zu tun da
darf ich mich nicht auf einem balkon in
kiew
dem fotografieren lassen mit einem
sektglas in der hand also meine damen
und herren politiker denken sie ein
bisschen darüber nach eine tierhandlung
ankommt lieber alles im verkehr dann
dann sollte es meinetwegen irgendwo im
keller machen nach luftschutzkeller
vielleicht ja wie finden sie denn das
argument jetzt hier von herrn kraus
politik darf aber nur im verborgenen und
wurden sie denn auch zuletzt im flugzeug
oder in der bahn mit der masken pflicht
konfrontiert und ja auch überprüft in
der bahn tatsächlich als den skiurlaub
gefahren sind aber ich kann zu dem
ganzen thema eigentlich alles ganz
schnell ab und ich bin ja britischer
staatsbürger auch und ich habe gesehen
wie meine verwandtschaft und über unser
verhalten unser umgang corona denkt die
verstehen ist einfach nicht mehr und ich
muss ja nicht so weit fahren nach
großbritannien ich vereinfache roller
nach polen also ich kann es nicht
nachvollziehen wir reden über den
gleichen virus oder denselben virus
sogar und deswegen sind die maßnahmen
hier einfach nicht mehr haltbar nicht
mehr nachzuvollziehen und doppelmoral da
kommen wir gleich drauf also da ist ja
nichts neues was sagen sie richtig
temperaturen natürlich ja natürlich aber
jetzt auch meine frage wie muss ich
jetzt noch mal stellen dass politiker
herr zeit gesprochen nicht mag ja
loyalität man sollte loyal zu seinem
chef seines urlaubs auch zum
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
finde ich gut aber jetzt mal dass bürger
herz sprechen lassen wenn man im zug
sitzt niemand ist da und dann kommt der
controller was mir auch dann passiert
bis sie die maske auf das kann man doch
nicht mehr gutheißen oder ob man das gut
heißt man kann natürlich fragen ob das
sinn macht na also sollten wir darüber
reden das infektionsschutzgesetz läuft
bis zum 18 19 ja dann müssen wir das
wieder verlängern aber sollten wir reden
welche maßnahmen sind machen welche
nicht und dafür bin ich auch ich habe
zwei jahre in schweden gelebt anderthalb
jahre unter krone habe also auch erlebt
wie man das anders handeln kann also man
kann das durchaus mal diskutieren nach
spd denn eine frage noch glaubt die spd
den dass das virus schlimmer ist in
deutschland als beispielsweise in
großbritannien ich glaube mich dass die
spd das glaubt
der glaubt dass herr lauterbach glaubt
bestimmt ist also es gefährlicher essen
ja das denke ich schon es ist ein
gewaltiges versagen nicht nur der
regierung sondern auch der
vorgängerregierung wir haben dieses
virus jetzt seit zweieinhalb jahren und
wenn ich mir dann den evaluationsbericht
der sachverständigenkommission anschauen
160 seiten lang nur wischiwaschi ja
verdammt noch mal hat man denn nicht
international recherchieren können was
die impfung bringt was die
nebenwirkungen sind was eine normale
medizinische maske bringt was seine fb2
maß geprägt wurde die masken in der
schule etwas gebracht haben fairerweise
muss man aber sagen dass wir zumindest
diese diskussion ins parlament zurück
geholt haben weil es eine
merkel-regierung einer regierung
entschieden wurde er hatte teilen die
erfolgsformel zahlen jetzt haben wir
alle gemeinsam getan und jetzt
entscheiden die volksvertreter darüber
gut angeblich recht ich bin nicht was
ich mache haben wieder kritisiert dieser
debatte die die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sie das
entschieden hat ist kein organ des
grundgesetzes gibt auch das hat eine
selbstermächtigung insofern ist es gut
dass in den bundestag
ist zurückgekommen ist aber mit den
ergebnissen bin ich nicht zufrieden das
merke ich das ist gut temperatur mögen
wir hierbei fehler aber eine frage ich
noch mal eine frau riekel als fdp
politiker jetzt wie enttäuscht sind sie
denn von der fdp und auch von marco
buschmann vielleicht
ob ich enttäuscht werden also sie werden
doch nicht jetzt annehmen dass ich jetzt
hier über herrn lindner oder muss man
die herzen aber es ist doch die menschen
halten sie verteilen ja dir lieber mal
und pattaya schluss verfahren ja wie
gesagt auch was ihnen nicht gefällt ja
fdp gefällt vieles an der fdp mir
gefällt vor allem diese unbedingte drang
nach freiheit und selbstbestimmung das
betrifft ja auch mein thema wenn es also
um energieverbrauch geht also ich möchte
mir ja nicht von der politik in meinem
privatleben vor allem nicht in meine
hygienemaßnahmen hineinreden lassen und
weil heute mitgebracht das thema wo aber
ja auch die fdp mit macht könnte man
sagen gleich gezwungen gezwungen da
erlaube ich das mache